the Joe Rogan experience I think that
we're living in its age now of you know
like this all the time everything is
just being broadcast all the time and
there's no such thing as like digging up
a pass anymore because everyone just put
their put their life out there maybe you
just go digging through someone's
Twitter feed or YouTube history whatever
you want to do so there's this wave
coming up like the Octavio Cortes and
and and people like that that are like
yeah it's all out there I don't care
about that here's what I want to do and
I think a generation is gonna come up
there that are that will go oh yeah I
tweeted out stupid [ __ ] when I was 18
yeah I don't you know when was that
tweet from ten years ago it doesn't
count whatever she was being an idiot I
was being like this standards are
definitely different now than they were
five years ago
but there's a generation of people
putting luminol on people's online
history that that will die out and and
it'll turn into you know if it was
something horrible a week ago yes let's
talk about that if you dug up something
someone did ten years ago everyone's
gonna go yeah you should see this [ __ ] i
but like that won't that won't land the
way that it is now yeah I think our
expectations of people are different we
don't we're not under the illusion
anymore that these aren't real people
because we want them to be presidential
or we want the mutia represented we're
not under the illusion anymore that they
that are that they're not real people
it's almost like when they had to admit
that WWE was fake it's like okay now we
could just enjoy it for what it is you
don't have to have these arguments with
your friends over whether or not it's
fake you know think about the WWE that
everyone keeps um forgetting is yes it's
scripted but it's scripted mayhem and
destruction they are scripting out these
people these men and women going in this
script you're going to fall 40 feet onto
a table of glass yes we scripted that to
happen but it's still a person doing
that yes like there's a level of
adrenaline junkie 'no stand athleticism
that goes beyond i think athletics yeah
some people like you know wrestling's
fake yeah no [ __ ] these people it's like
when you watch a Jackie Chan
film doctor scripted film to stick
around for the end credits he just got
his skull knocked open
yeah they literally punched a hole
through his skull doing a stunt so
you're you're you're dismissing
something your definition of fake needs
to be tweaked a little bit in this case
yeah it's another way of looking at it
it's it's it's definitely it's
definitely scripted it's not like
they're risking it all because they
don't know what the outcomes gonna be
it's different than an actual athletic
event but it's still pretty badass like
as far as what they're able to do I mean
yes they don't get nearly enough credit
for it either because while they were
doing it before the the lockdown maybe
they were doing it 250 plus days a year
traveling all over the country throwing
each other on tables in those days you
know skating was still very much a
novelty and then in the 90s like X Games
came into play and then all of a sudden
my name was was being well it was well
known not mainstream but but getting
there and then our video game came out
and then it was just like oh you're just
a sellout and it was like because of the
video game because the video game the
endorsements that followed from that you
know I was doing stuff for Jeep from
McDonald's for Doritos and they were
just like oh you just a so I was like
when I turned pro at age 14 if
McDonald's had asked me to be in a
commercial I would have jumped on it are
you kidding me like I was eating
McDonald's my whole life I still do so
it was more like they thought someone I
changed my values and was just like I
haven't changed my value system it's
just that I'm getting these
opportunities finally and I've been
doing this for most of my life for the
most part it's you're getting
opportunities that they're not so the
best way to dismiss that or diminish it
is to say that you're a sellout because
you're on a video game that's so
short-sighted sure but but you know but
so what I'm saying is that just sort of
that sort of sealed my resolve where so
once the social media came into play and
people are talking [ __ ] online I was
like you're not getting to me this you
know this through this media right
people used to say this to my face used
to write about this just write about me
in magazines like you're hiding behind
your Twitter username I don't
when you first saw someone say that you
were cheating by using that technique
how bad that must have sucked up yeah
and it was from it was from a skater
that I really respected too he was
quoted in the magazine and that was it
was crushing wow that's such a bitch-ass
approach you know cheating that's so
weird to me because I never would have I
guess it makes sense because there's
always factions in any discipline or any
art form or anything where some people
respect some things and other people
[ __ ] on it and but the idea that you
doing it your way would somehow or
another be cheating to me it seems so
strange that doesn't make any sense like
I said it was it was just weird because
skating was there's a small community at
the time I knew it was like why are you
like why are we fighting in our little
tiny world that's always gonna be that
way
yeah that's just humans yeah especially
when you're doing something different
especially if you're getting attention
doing something different they're gonna
find some way to diminish you yeah it
was just it was it was harder for me
because all I wanted to be was accepted
as a skater mm-hmm you know I kind of
given up on my peers on my schoolmates I
knew I wasn't gonna fit in there and so
I was like I found this thing and
they're just like you guys don't like I
mean either way I do it rough a real
parallel is when you were talking about
these large scale meat processing plants
are a perfect sort of petri dish for
viruses to grow so our factory farms so
are these farms where your stuff in pigs
next to each other you're doing all this
unnatural stuff right it's unnatural for
people to be stuffed into a warehouse
right next to each other shoulders
shoulder working all day it's unnatural
for them to be stuffed in these homes
shoulder-to-shoulder with bad food and
and all the things that you would need
to keep your body healthy and strong the
same can be said about these factory
farms in situations one thing that I
find so attractive about the way you run
your farm is that there's no weirdness
in watching these animals during the day
they seem like animals just doing normal
stuff if you see a chicken wandering
around just pecking at the grass looks
normal see a chicken in a cage getting
fed out of a little copper so
it looks all kinds of [ __ ] up right it
doesn't feel right no no that's what we
you know we we have the phrase
respecting the pigness of the pig and
the chicken is of the chicken and we
know that these diseases are all coming
from these place I mean there's a ton of
agricultural diseases you know that are
based from these factories you have
situations where these animals live in
these really horrific conditions and
then the bacteria jump and look I mean
they're they're they're eat look if you
ate in your toilet every it would you
like to eat your toilet every day right
that's that's how they eat you're there
breathing in their fecal particulate
matter which is you know putting lesions
in there tender respiratory membranes
making making lesions there Minh and so
when you have those kinds of conditions
and they're not getting exercise or not
getting fresh air and so I mean the the
they're not getting salad they're not
getting any vitamin D from the sunshine
and so what happens is you get an
extremely concentrated host host
facility for pathogenicity mmm that's
what happens you get a very concentrated
host facility because there's always a
host they're close to each other the
pathogen doesn't have to say Wow boy I
wonder if I can make it that you know
that half mile over to another no oh
they're you know they're always right
there and so you're right it's like it's
like an incubator and so you know if we
wanted to sit down look if we wanted to
sit down and say let's say we had a
James Bond conspiracist you know and
said we're gonna form a committee and
and make a pathogen friendly farm you
know the old James Bond nemesis right
and so we form a committee say how can
we make a pathogen friendly farm well we
would have only one species we'd crowded
up we'd take out the oxygen the the
fresh air the sunshine we'd give it we'd
give it a minimal a minimalistic diet
what I've just described is modern
efficient industrial factory farming you
couldn't design a better system for for
conductivity of pathogenicity the
government doesn't really seem to have
any sort of straightforward plan as to
how people can economically bounce back
from this they I mean there was one of
the weirdest quotes I think it was Trump
that said this we're talking about
businesses and restaurants that they'll
be open maybe not with the same owners
but they'll be open again did you did
you see that quote no I don't I don't I
didn't see that but it's like what does
that really mean does that just mean
like a different business will be
created exactly what it means it means
that he's just being pragmatic and maybe
cold whoever made that quote that is
probably how it's gonna go down is it
Trump says restaurants to make comeback
just maybe with new owners yeah I mean
that don't that does not make me feel
good Ben if I'm a restaurant owner you
know and there's a few restaurants that
I'm always shouting out on the podcast
that like are owned by friends of mine
that are these businesses are hurting so
bad they're they've went like that to no
customers or a very small percentage of
customers who were to take out when they
were you know they had dine in every
night and they have these bills and they
had their business set up in a way that
you know you have to make X amount of
money in order to stay open and they
were successful and they're doing well
and one of the toughest businesses to be
successful in and then all sudden the
rug gets pulled out so what's the
solution should people just be able to
go to restaurants and everybody works
there as a waiter or a cook or they just
maybe get sick and then more people die
boy that doesn't sound good to anybody
either so what is the solution I don't
know but I don't think that in our
particular case I don't think our
governor has the answers one of the
things he's been criticized for is he's
decided to open up production for
television and films but not churches
you know there's another thing they've
done that's really nuts and my friend
Adam curry turned me on to they closed
Alcoholics Anonymous meetings but liquor
stores were an essential business that
is yes that's not good government it's
not good thinking this is this there's
so many things where they put into place
these lists of what's approved and not
approved and I don't think that it's an
int
first of all I think the information is
constantly changing and I think that
they're going off this old information
they haven't made adjustments and then
on top of it I don't think they're
qualified to I don't think they're
qualified just like we're talking about
a president like one person who's
involved in the economy and environment
all these different things I don't think
one governor can really be smart enough
to know a what kind of impact is gonna
have economically to close all these
businesses down and B which ones get to
open up and what is essential and why
and it's just it's very frustrating for
all involved and it highlights one of
the reasons why you know the way we do
government is tight it's you know it's
not perfect it's it's not it's
definitely better than a lot of ways a
lot of places in the world but it stills
there's a lot of holes in it
[Applause]